hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today's
episode I have a conversation with an
old friend of mine who happens to also
be enormous ly respected scientist and
writer jan 11 a.m. ain't Eanes both an
active research program she's a
professor of physics at Columbia
University in Barnard College where she
thinks about black holes and cosmology
and astrophysics in various ways
but also a broader effort to interact
with other disciplines and with the
general public but we choose slightly
different ways of going about that
broader impact kind of sector of our
efforts in particular what Jana has done
is mastered a way of writing about
science that is fundamentally narrative
in focus and tone her books that explain
science to a broader public really read
like novels in fact one of them is
basically a novel she mixes the human
side of science with the actual research
being done better than anyone else that
I know so we'll talk a little bit about
her research because that's always you
know where things come from in some
sense but mostly about the book she's
written and why she chooses to write
about science in this way her most
recent book which I recommend that you
read is called black hole blues and it's
about the discovery of gravitational
waves the building of the LIGO
Observatory and all the effort that went
into that over the years so this
conversation serves as an interesting
companion piece to my conversation with
Kip Thorne from just a couple of
episodes ago as Kip was there he was one
of the people who was interviewed by
Jana
for his efforts in helping to build Lego
and make it happen so you get different
sides of the same story which is
interesting to compare ok this talk has
two old friends talking at great length
there's lots of laughs I think you're
gonna enjoy this ride let's go
[Music]
channel 11 welcome to the mindscape
podcast ah thanks for having me so as
we've been reminiscing here
pre-recording we've known each other for
a long time we were graduate students
but not at the same place you started
out as at MIT and I went to Harvard
so tell just tell us a little bit about
the trajectories scientifically like
what you started trying to study and
where you are now well I mean mostly we
usually talk about our meeting story
what would we own it we were on him what
would they call tram shanty god so cute
it's got the team yeah and I think I was
reading Burrell and Davies quantum field
theory in curved space-time as you do
clearly as you do yes tall skinny dude
like hey I know
Berlin Davies a guy I knew who's trying
to hit on you I tried to like save you
by saying like wait aren't you reading a
book on quantum field theory of
space-time so basically yes you you
derailed yeah that me afterward it was
he he should be what now he shouldn't be
I was not mad at you okay
so that's basically been friend sense
which is kind of hilarious
that's right it is extremely hilarious
but you studied a lot we studied a lot
together there were a lot of problems
that's a lot of problem sense a lot of
discussions about whether coffee should
have milk in it or not how much coffee
should be drunk after midnight this is
very important crucial decision making
um so I would say that in terms of
trajectory I was definitely not that kid
he thought it was gonna be a scientist
and you know I discovered it really late
I had really negative ideas about
science and physics in particular which
is really kind of hilarious it's like my
punishment in life was to become a
physicist and have to that's really
define the identity so I think that one
thing that you and I always really
enjoyed when we were even students
was the sort of creative aspect of
physics and how there are different
solutions and different ways to approach
things and and that it's like cracking
the walnut you find these really clever
insights and it's just this pleasure
it's this pleasure to be connected to
the universe through this medium which
is wild that it works and I and I feel
like you and I kind of grew up together
with that learning that not not like
high school college level but like
feeling it yeah because in graduate
school that you first get to sort of be
right up close and personal with the
universe and something right right right
right and we're still asking the most
naive questions then I hope yes and a
lot of people do something in grad
school and then end up doing it for
their lives all right
yeah it's not exactly what you've done
no that's true um tell us what science
you did in grad school well gosh I was
kind of lost in grad school to be honest
because I wasn't at my happiness point
but I was definitely working on
alternative theories of gravity and
space-time stuff and how to interpret
the Big Bang but I don't think it was my
best work I mean I know it's not my best
work I think that a lot of that came
later with sort of more fluency in lots
of different subjects and less trying to
prove something to somebody right
graduate school was very much about
making sure your professors thought a
certain thing about you so that you
could go on yeah and and my most
creative work definitely came I think
later when I felt less of that you know
less less constrained by what other
people thought yeah so you got into a
whole bunch of you know interesting
buzzwords stirred together with chaos
theory and topology and cosmology and
black holes
yeah it's like oh that's tough so what
does it mean either to do science well
it's funny so I think that right from a
distance it looks like none of the
things I'm interested in have a coherent
theme but they all do really which is
basically space-time physics is
basically the coherent terrain on which
all the other stuff plays out so even
when I've done chaos theory which I
learned a lot from other people just
bike
writing with other people who were very
thoughtful about dynamical systems it's
the best way to learn actually is is
from other scientists so very much
borrowing and sharing and collaborating
on chaos theory from people like Neil
Cornish it all happened in a curved
space-time that's where we were
interested in and one of the most
interesting questions was you know chaos
is usually defined as a loss of
predictability over time an exponential
deviation over time but you can't define
a singular time in relativity that's the
whole point so suddenly you have this
what does it mean to be chaotic what are
there unambiguous declarations and chaos
really does mean that there are not
functional solutions - sorry my phone
goddamnit I thought I put it on silent
you know that there are not functional
solutions to the equations of motion
that's unambiguous it can't be ambiguous
whose time what time so a lot of the fun
we had was to try to make understandable
declarations of chaos that were the same
for all observers in space-time well
this actually puzzled me about chaos
still always puzzled me about chaos
maybe because I learned relativity first
you know in relativity time is up to you
you can choose time however you want so
you could have a logarithmic time or
something like that where the Cask goes
away technically the other way around
I'm thinking like if two things diverge
only linearly with time I'll define law
time to be like I'm so Deanna succeed
what we realized is that in a lot of
these systems what you can look at is
the possibility of large sets so for
instance large numbers of orbits around
black holes whether they merge or escape
or are stable that you can begin to find
fractal sets in the space of
possibilities and fractals are
unambiguous recreations of chaotic
behavior because what what's happening
with a fractal which is so smart that
nature does it figures out a way to pack
tons of information in the smallest
space possible right so our head
can remain volume-wise small ish but
surface wise very large by having lots
of fractal folds because the brain is a
two-dimensional sheet crumpled up and
see exactly crumpling it up making it a
fractal allows you to have this huge
surface area without scaling up the
volume which we couldn't support on our
little necks and to whammy what are you
looking at in the black hole you're like
throwing a particle lattice and come
down
yeah like here's an example two black
holes can be arranged to be completely
static with charge and gravity balancing
so they're charged so they're
electromagnetically repulsive but
they're massive so they were
gravitationally attractive and you can
tune it just on paper to be perfectly
these material experiments these do not
exist in the in astrophysics but the
orbits of stuff around nose tube will be
like a pinball game it'll be like a
complex game of pimple and so what you
can do is look at the fractal set of
possibilities so how many little things
you throw in there fall in how many
little things escape how many little
things are stable and if you start to
try to very precisely define whether
it's stable merging or escaping no
matter how precise you try to make those
definitions you still find a mixture of
all possibilities right and that's
classic fractal behavior that you'd look
closer and closer and you still can't
pinpoint what happens because a subtle
subtle dependence and the tiniest
difference in the initial condition
leads to the exactly opposite outcome so
what we did show was that the fractal
dimension was related to things like the
Lyapunov exponent which is measures and
times what that is
I know oh jeez it's my fault oh my god
that was really naughty so if it was
just ordinary space we would say that
the time scale over which there was a
divergence and predictability was set by
something called the Lyapunov exponent
but because of what you raised about the
ambiguity of time in relativity it's
different for every different observer
so we were basically able to show the
the fractal dimension was the same for
all observers it was a good combination
of things like yep enough time scale and
a spatial time doesn't details don't
matter but it but it was it everybody
would agree that the fractal was there
and this is a classic thing that
physicists like to do that you can sort
of calculate something one way but you
worry that it depends on how you
calculated it so look for something you
can show everyone would agree on this no
matter how they calculate it yeah
physics is really hard yeah so what you
want is a measure of something that's
the same for all observers that's really
what you strive for so you know as you
well know and in relativity you can't
say time is the same for all observers
you can't say spaces is the same for all
observers but you can say that there's a
space time interval right which is a
measure in the four-dimensional
space-time which is the same for all
observers and that's really gratifying
mm-hm and that you can orient all your
interpretations around that invariant
and it has did this interest in the
chaotic behavior of particles going
around black holes lead you later to
think about real Astrophysical black
holes that are out there
it did oh my god that's crazy and I
think you and I also suffer from this a
little bit which is that in our youngest
years being most fascinated with the
most abstract most surreal maybe not
astrophysically relevant right and
because there was something about it
that just appealed to our tastes yeah so
for the audience out there there are
astrophysicists where as I keep saying
relatively down-to-earth you despite
feeling astrophysics right like they're
worried about real stuff we see it in
telescopes we understand the underlying
physics but then there's some of us who
go right to the edges of what we
understand because a little fuzzy here
yeah and I think that there's still that
pole for me but a part of as I started
to sort of think about you know what's
your contribution and what comes back to
you I wanted to see something predicted
and verified yeah the
nature at the end of the day it's about
nature at the end of the day this total
and I'd love to call it an unrequited
love for nature she does not love us
back she is quite indifferent playing
hard to get she is very hard to get so I
think that there was this sense of oh
god if there was one thing just one
thing and I'll go back to my insane
abstractions but one thing that was
verifiable while I was alive like that
would feel so good it would be so fun it
would be very childlike fun right you
know just exploratory and and then
there's he so yes it did lead me from
being completely theoretical imagined
models of black holes to wait a minute
there are real black holes they're out
there that's pretty cool there are
things that we can say about them that
people haven't said yet it's still in
some sense accessible to discovery so I
started getting really into more how
black holes could contribute to like
electronic circuits and weird things
like that the wait a minute so I think
that the typical person listening is
going now electronic circuits I do build
oh yeah lab room and I said things
together in a light bulb yams up so how
do I like stick a wire into the black
hole and light a light bulb or what
happens it's so funny it's one of these
things that I learned as a student but
always never really understood and one
of the things if I try to tell my
students now is that if you don't
understand something keep leaning on it
because maybe you're gonna crack
something that everyone else has been
glib about and this was sort of one of
those examples which was black holes
have no hair meaning they cannot support
complicated things like magnetic field
lines that magnetic field lines if you
remember in high school throwing iron
shavings around a magnet and seeing the
path of the field lines traced out that
you couldn't see with your eyes but that
the iron filings trace out for you that
you see it literally looks like
hair yeah coming out of the top of a
head and then usually going into the
chin perfectly spherical head it's a
hair beard and the earth has such a
magnetic field neutron stars have very
big magnetic jewels
formerly proved cannot support the hair
of magnetic fields meaning they just
can't have them so I I was always
confused about that because as you said
neutron stars how these big magnetic
fields there can be a trillion times
that of the earth they're literally the
strongest magnets in the universe
neutron stars they're they're almost
black holes but not quite they're dead
stars that don't make it to be black
holes and if a black hole swallows one
which we suspect happens quite
frequently what happens the magnetic
field and there was always this very
glib argument and I think that it just
by not accepting the standard lore and
just sort of scratching at it just being
stubborn
you know we realized that there's this
phase where the huge magnet is whipping
around the black hole and it's going to
create an electronic circuit so I
disconnect a light bulb out of a lamp I
don't have a lamp here and I disconnect
the light but when I hold it in my hand
in principle absolute basic electricity
magnetism no relativity no black holes
nothing fancy
if I wave a magnet around strongly
enough I will light up that lightbulb it
doesn't need to be plugged into a
battery or the wall or anything so I
create electricity by a waving magnet
because the magnetic field stretches
away from the magnet so even though you
don't see it there's something
stretching from the magnet to the light
bulb varying magnetic fields create
electric fields not spooky action it's
not spooky action distance it's
completely predictable it's totally
normal it's totally natural and so
basically that's what we have we have
this magnet whipping around near the
speed of light around the black hole and
it's creating actually an incredibly
powerful electronic circuit I don't know
how we were the first ones to point this
out this is basic they from like 1885 is
so much
things like that like someone must have
pointed this out therefore I won't think
about it right and then you lose the
chance yeah yeah and also this no-hair
theorem which is so lovely doesn't say
that the black hole
can't have a magnetic field it says it
can only have a magnetic field
consistent with these certain
circumstances the stuff around it
exactly and charge much we can get into
it so so that's fun I mean I was drawing
circuit diagrams for like the biggest
most powerful batteries in the universe
well you know it seems like you we're
just doing it for fun but that's where a
lot of great science comes from right
like why care about chaos and black
holes or electric circuits and black
holes like part of the motivation might
be not just for this is going to lead us
to the super secret of the universe it's
just kind of cool and that's where super
secret sometimes get revealed yeah and I
I think when people and I know you and I
have also had this conversation
privately but when people say things
like it's murdering two dice actor
doesn't it make you feel glum or despair
that the universe is this you know
they're in the black I don't know how
you can walk away for this and not feel
meaning right not feel exactly the
opposite which is how are we so
fortunate to be connected to the origin
of the universe through math what a gift
and that it's so meaningful and so
moving so we absolutely do this for
emotional reasons yeah which is fine
there are no other reasons right that's
what the reasons to come here exactly
and this is a great segue right into
what I mostly want to talk about was
you've been extraordinarily successful
in addition to the science at things
science adjacent especially in telling
stories telling stories strictly about
science or scientifically inflected you
know and you you've written several
books a memoir a novel and narrative
history so in every case you know
there's a story going on so maybe I
don't know whether you'd want to tell us
about the first book or tell us about
the underlying motivation
yeah throughout them
I'm super interested in structure and
writing and I think we are all taught to
write very very badly and and I was a
philosophy student for philosophers and
this is also another conversation we
have to get into I learned to write so
badly and I saw it because I felt
because I loved philosophers for the
physicist he told you just as badly oh
my god even worse even worse writing
passive construction and it was shown by
and you know it is known that whatever
it's terrible and but I I grew up loving
books and loving loving narrative and
loving fiction not so much nonfiction
I'm actually not a huge nonfiction
reader so it was so much the power of
fiction fiction is so rich and it's so
complicated and it's so interesting and
so every time I sat down to write a book
I would be lost in terms of structure
structure was always the hardest thing
what am i doing structurally it's not
what am I trying to say that was in some
sense more accessible yeah yeah I kind
of knew what that was but how to say it
was so challenging in a time and time
again I would throw away entire books
the second poke especially which ended
up being a novel I tried to write it as
a straightforward non-fiction expository
math proof sort of discussion about what
can be known and what can't be known
right on no ability of certain
mathematical this is a book about
touring and girls yeah turning a girdle
and it just was wrong and so I threw
away an entire book in order to write
this other thing which was a novel which
structurally seemed to be truer which
was to say there are some facts we
cannot know simply by listing the data
or in mathematics we would say the
transformation rules from the axioms do
not always yield a theorem which is
verifiable within the context of that
you know right what's the word I'm
looking for that that's
the formal system yeah that formal
system and and so the whole idea of the
novel was there are some truths we can
only get to by stepping outside by being
fictionalized or by being narrative or
by being right so to say that of course
it has to be a novel exactly so it
became a novel with an unreliable
narrator who doesn't know the truth but
it's grasping for the truth and it was
such a pleasure to write it was such a
pleasure once I was a terrible pain
before I realized that but once I made
that decision it just became this fluid
I just knew what I was doing is there
something besides the obvious that drew
you to touring and gore Alan Turing
famous computer scientist and Kurt
kurtal famous mathematician logician I
mean they're both fascinating characters
but did they I'm sorry this is the one
book of yours I haven't read so I think
I have to confess that right from the
start okay we're gonna go right now were
they close no okay so how do they fit
together I think oh well that's a good
question John because I think the way
that people rarely ask me that because
they don't fit together that well except
for cumulatively they're proof is about
limitations of what we can know but I
think I was fascinated by the fact that
Turing became such a cool hearted
atheist and that God will continue to
believe in an afterlife where he would
be reincarnated and find a more platonic
existence in a pure mathematical state
like I just think that that despite the
fact that they started in the same
intellectual mathematical core yeah that
they had these wildly divergent beliefs
and that's actually why I think I paired
them why don't we just be very
straightforward it because I'm realizing
you and I know who these people are but
maybe not everyone does fan who is Alan
Turing
okay so Alan Turing became very famous
as a very young mathematician for
realizing that there were some numbers
that were uncomputable meaning literally
if you tried to mechanize thought and so
here he invented the computer so this is
why Alan Turing is most famous just
point blank fret inventing the entire
idea of the computer which at the time
was a word for people who calculated
things but we now understand as a
machine that's able to do lots of
flexible stuff yeah and they used to be
called universal Turing machines after
Turing but Turing's idea was to imagine
mechanizing thought and figuring out a
way and which theorems work and proofs
work and in that process he proved that
there were numbers that could never be
computed in a form shorter than the
number itself right so let's say I have
a number point one two three five seven
nine it goes on and on for infinity the
code to generate that number is exactly
as long as the number right note shorter
which is not true of like the number two
or three fours become a number two is
true
two plus two is five right it's horrible
yes the square root of two is actually
in it's an irrational number but it is
computable in a very short code exactly
so the difference between square root of
two and these other numbers was that
there was no code that could be written
no mechanized system that could be
devised that would yield the number any
more quickly than just randomly tossing
the die of what the next digit should be
after the decimal point okay so it
sounds very abstract but what it means
is that there are facts about numbers
simple numbers numbers between zero and
one about which we will never know
anything not only that but there's an
infinite number of such numbers not only
that but it's the largest infinity of
the numbers between zero and one most
numbers most numbers are numbers about
which we will never know anything okay
so this is a cutting revelation in the
time when people are trying to recover
from the wars and they're trying to find
solid
and rationality and they're trying to
find you know some sense so this belief
that everything can be rational Noble
and suddenly there's this kick in the
teeth well yeah this is all not only in
the aftermath of world war two but in
the early days of 20th century we had
this optimism about mathematics Russell
and Whitehead Hilbert that had this
program we're gonna set out some axioms
we're gonna prove every true thing
totally so here comes you know like
Turing is a strange character he's
lovely but he's very likely autistic
openly gay and persecuted for his
homosexuality and also contributed
significantly to the war effort turning
the tide in favor of the Allies Britain
yet is breaking codes and yet is
convicted of homosexuality and given
hormone treatments which leave him you
know depressed and devastated and
suicidal and so it is largely believed
that he takes his own life he was
obsessed with snow white which had
recently been aired you know what's
screened and he bit from a poison apple
an apple that he dipped in cyanide and
so some people say things like which
might be apocryphal but that the Mac
symbol of the half-eaten Apple the apple
with the bite out of it as a reference
deterring cuz Turing does invent the
computer in this indirect way right
because he start what he's really
thinking about his mechanizing thought
nope and then he not only says sure I
bet I could build a machine that could
think as well as we do that machines
could think that there's AI so he's a
he's really the the father of AI but
then he says we are machines yeah that
think so then he becomes as sort of cool
atheist that he gives up all of this
other stuff and says we simply are
machines and and I think we've been
playing catch-up with Turing ever since
yeah yeah
and meanwhile Austrian electrician Kurt
girdle gosh Austrian yeah
God Oh home of any number of famous
brilliant crazy people lots I think I
have a little bit of a thing for crazy
brilliant I do pretty well new you are
here god I was so fascinating because he
predates Turing and he makes the first
blow
so hilbert as you said is this brilliant
mathematician he's the most powerful
mathematician of the era it's turn of
the century and Hilbert calls for a
proof that all true facts among the
numbers can't be proven to be true he
doesn't literally mean he wants a list
of an infinite number of proofs that he
has he done he just wants a proof that
it can be done and everyone expects that
this isn't true I mean why wouldn't you
expect assist you so girdle is the one
who deals the first blow before Turing
turns very influenced by qoodles work
and even though they never met and
girdle shows really it's so lovely the
way he does it that that there are facts
among the numbers that can never be
proven to be true and his is more to
veins true fact well at least what is
the technical statements like either the
the formal system is inconsistent that's
true or there are true facts he rejected
inconsistency so either there's a
bold-faced paradox in math which he
rejected or there are facts that can't
be proven to be true and that is largely
where people side yeah it would be much
worse if one plus one was sometimes two
and sometimes three so I wouldn't put it
past those mathematicians they come up
with all sorts of crazy idea and sir
gödel initiated up blow but he was you
know he was a strange character he was
very isolated and very withdrawn and and
had strange ideas about the afterlife
and
platonism he really believed in math was
real in a physical sense
I can never draw a circle but there's no
such thing as a perfect circle in
reality but he believed at them and
maybe he's right I don't know that the
mental experiment of a perfect circle is
sufficient to prove it exists and I
think that's insightful yeah he was a
little crazy girl but then so but they
have this thing in common where there's
something that always slips through your
fingers the more you tighten your grip
fry than something true about the
universe that we can never grasp
yes what gödel did and actually oh sure
we should talk about this later what God
did which was so clever was he
constructed a sentence which basically
says this this true statement can never
be proven right and then he translated
it through a very clever cipher into a
purely arithmetic statement that was
just like about numbers yeah and proved
that that equation was correct and
therefore unprovable right which were
provable it would have to be incorrect
cuz they even said it's unprovable and
right now it is possible that you try to
construct such a sentence and you cannot
mathematize it right and you don't prove
anything but he mathematize it perfectly
and there it was and ever since then
every mathematician who's been trying to
prove things and getting stuck is always
wondering like is this way but it's not
provable yeah yeah it's rarely true so I
I know I'm sure you get asked this a lot
to choose oh don't you think that
something we'll never know and my
argument is until somebody proves to me
we can never know it and that can't
happen we have examples of that in
history and turning and go dog yeah then
we keep trying and then so you're this
these are fascinating stories obviously
very important human intellectual
history blah blah blah so at what point
did you say the right way to tell the
story is via story via a novel I think
just cuz I failed so bad yeah telling it
as nonfiction it just wasn't working it
wasn't it wasn't interesting it didn't
it would have not reached I just feel
like sometimes we experience an element
of truth in the solar plexus like yeah
we just feel it through the narrative
and that that spoke so much more even to
the promise of there are things that we
can only know by stepping outside and
looking in I mean that is really
ultimately go tools lesson is that you
know it's true because you step outside
of the mathematical system and you
reflect on it and you can declare it's
true and that there was something about
narrative that allowed you to do exactly
that
right so I basically wanted to structure
the narrative on the premise of the
theorems but I thought it would reach
people much more than if I forced them
to go through the agony of Cantor's
diagonal zation okay just because that
was an extremely elegant and compelling
rational rationale for why yeah but did
you have that before you wrote the novel
no again I only had it after I feel that
right or nonfiction but you know but
before you wrote the novel version did
you say like oh maybe I need to step out
of the system okay by then by dad by the
time that I had given way like a most of
sorry fruit and three books and almost
everyone I write the wrong book first
yeah and I bomb out and then I figure
out what the right it's right it's my
process so I definitely you know it was
painful
it wasn't feel it didn't feel good until
I abandoned that first approach and then
thought okay
I mean maybe I'm gonna try this and a
lot of it is just boring you don't have
permission I mean we're all sort of like
that a little bit do I have a permission
to do this am I gonna get slammed by my
colleagues is my editor gonna be furious
is my agent gonna kill me you know so I
have to hide one of which is perfectly
reasonably implausible right I mean
these things happen right yeah they all
basically showed up at my door with
torture but that's even my last book the
third book was the same way I kept
trying to do the right thing to like do
what was expected of me right and
failing right and then just you have
this terrible moment you decide okay
what's worse
a bad book right for getting some flack
from ya and you know every single time
my agent and my editor and my scientist
friends have all stepped up so in
reality was all in my mind basically the
fear yeah
well but you had this previous
experience you'd already written one
book and and and that book how the
universe got its spots I've said it
before and I'll happy say it on tape was
one of my favorite books of all time and
it's a combination of you know narrative
your personal narrative right which is
yet another daring thing to do you're
not supposed to do that as a scientist
with an explication of the science of
cosmology and the topology of the
universe that book was definitely
written because I thought we would never
know the answer scientifically and so
you know you do
whether or not the universe was Infinite
or finite so this was a question we were
asking again because we could because it
was the math was fun the math was
accessible it's a big question it's a
great question did I honestly at no
point working on it scientifically did I
think it was going to be answered
observational II because like a year are
we talking here that you're writing oh
man it's like 15 years ago probably like
a little after the tournament the early
2000s and and honestly it's probably
never a question we're gonna answer the
universe could be finite it could be
wrapped onto itself but it's just so big
we'll never see you around and I knew
that that was likely it's not that I was
foolish scientifically thinking we were
gonna observe it but the question was
fun and it was fun to do and I think the
whole book was about what happens to
these ideas if they're not measurable
and this anxiety about being
disconnected not only from other people
because what I work on and what you are
I found is so weird and and difficult to
grasp but because it might not even end
up in the Canon right so basically could
these be wasted years because I was
fantasizing about something real
scientifically but not necessarily
measurable but this was a special case
it wasn't intrinsically unmeasurable
they were you know for certain answers
we could have measured that
the universe has been small and
telepathically interesting right but if
you had put it into my head I would have
said it's not that small yeah you would
right I mean there was no part of me
that was pushing it as this is gonna be
my big mark and yeah but it was just the
beauty also in the fascination of the
comfort talked about narrative the idea
that if light wraps around the universe
I can look far enough away in front of
them to pass that I could see myself or
the Milky Way or I could see Sean and I
studying for physics and that's how the
universe got its spot that is literally
how the universe got its spots
yeah but so at what point do you thence
I mean everyone we know has written a
book about cosmology but then you
decided to put your personal story in
there right like yeah is that something
that came in later did you get
resistance from your editor and
publisher yeah I think that that one
actually I knew that's how I wanted to
write it because partly at the time I
had no quote/unquote right to write a
book at that point we we come from a
field where you can write a book when
you're coming down from the mountain you
know with with the tablet right do your
thing firs tears come back as professor
emeritus and declare the results and
this was much more hey we are never
gonna have his result and so it was sort
of turning it on its head and I I think
so I thought a lot about how I don't
like that tone of I know things that I
am sharing with you my conclusion and I
think that that contributed to my really
negative idea about physics when I was a
kid and scientist when I was a kid is
that they simply recite facts or know
facts or have information so it's
definitely like physics is about not
knowing right and that's the fun and
that's the experiment and that's the
experience that leads you to be so lost
from more normal pleasures of life and
you know traveling all the time and
separated from your closests and your
dearest's
and so I think it was much more a clear
decision to not write the definitive
book of factual information but to more
write about the struggle the fact that
was in process was a feature not a bug
zactly in progress yeah yeah yeah but oh
okay but why did you put you into it is
this why because you wanted to reflect
the sort of psychological state you were
in while doing the research no I think I
was I was disciplining myself not to
sound you know what's the word not to
sound authoritative I think by choosing
a person to speak to which in this case
it was letters to my mum who somebody I
respect but is not a physicist that it
was a way for me to be respectful to my
audience not authoritative right exactly
and and kind of like to experience that
humility of the not knowing and so so I
I think that's why I chose her as my
target audience and I just thought why
not just declare that that's my target
audience why pretend otherwise why not
to say I'm writing this to her
he makes it subtext time yes yes just do
it just be blunt and I think it really
helped me find the voice for a first
book especially where you know voice ISM
you struggle to find voice yeah and even
when books are written up by famous
scientist but by you know journalists or
whoever they generally wait until the
result is in hand right and so yeah
there is this idea of a rational
reconstruction we tell the story Wow
it makes sense not how it happened and
you got to tell the story in all the
messiness right because there's so many
mistakes you make and yeah yeah blind
alleys you go down yeah and actually the
last book was was so much about that so
it's really funny because Ray Weiss who
won the Nobel Prize along with Kip
Thorne and Barry bearish for the
discovery of gravitational waves kept
saying to me when he realized that there
was a discovery he kept saying so what
do you do about the book there's like oh
my god ray I love to write that the book
was a bad
not knowing you know the tension the
anxiety the reality of failure like
looming so the book was about a
gravitational waves it was originally
about the search for gravity about the
search for cavitation turned into a
story of the discovery you've grown up a
lot and again I mean there's no way I
would have I could never had I known
about the discovery I mean I'm not sure
I could have maintained that sense of
the tension and the you know anxiety and
all of that stuff from climbing Mount
Everest aspect of that story I don't
know if I could have reproduced if I had
known it succeeded right so it was so
great to write it not knowing if they
were gonna succeed that the failure was
real and looming as a real possibility
but again you threw away tens of
thousands of words yeah different at
first conception I had a lot more stuff
about physics like I had a lot more
pedagogical kind of stuff and it wasn't
and it was what I was doing is I was
chickening out I was burying these
stories because I was really scared to
talk about ray nobody kept you know and
I love these guys they were really
important people to me they're they're
statesmen of the field and Kip
especially I mean I became very close
with right during the writing of the
book but I've known Kip since I was what
1918 something like that and he's always
been this wonderful supportive
inspiration and to write about him made
me incredibly uncomfortable because
there is dirty laundry in the leg of
stories right like it's not all just
increased it's not all great and I I was
trying to bury it I was chickening out
basically and that was a point where my
editor Dan Frank was fantastic because I
knew I was doing it but I wasn't sure if
other people would notice stop pulling
your punches that's low you still need
editors yeah
and in literally 24 hours I threw away
half the book I was so easy to
disconnect cuz it just didn't belong
there it was like literally like two
disconnected pieces jam together and I
took one and I threw it away and there
was the book but it sounds like someday
the future there's gonna be a thousand
page yeah you know exposition of bursts
well and Cantor's diagonal zation
theorem all these pedagogical things
you've written and have never seen the
light of day right there in there I mean
I think especially with Goethe lantern
that there were better versions written
but you know black calls is sort of my
thing
yeah I got a I got a little jive for me
and black holes we got something going
on you know I have to say the most
amazing thing about both Kipp and Ray is
that on the day of the discovery the day
that the instruments about which I was
writing and that they designed recorded
the first sound of black holes colliding
by coincidence I printed a draft of the
book one for Ray and one for Kevin sent
it to them and and what was amazing is
that neither of them told me not to say
something so for instance Kipp took
issue with certain things but what he
did
being the scientist all the way through
to them very bitter and presented me
with all the evidence of the contrary
argument and I included the
counter-argument but he never said take
it out never said suppress it never said
he said instead err also the
counter-arguments a true scientist it's
a true scientist and Ray to Ray was like
I don't like it but that's true and he
said it's a shame it's in the public
record but it doesn't have to be in your
book and that quote is in the book yeah
that's right having it be that way
exactly
but again the deep so your third book
was in yet another mode right you had
the sort of memoir exposition first and
then you had a historical novel and in
this one you're almost like the new
journalist right like you are going
embedding yourself in the LIGO
experiment talking to people think I
mean recording conversation
honestly for the first six months I
didn't think to record cuz I'm not a
journalist tell me Jesus I got so
recorded in this stuff because I was
transcribing so frantically afterwards
trying to remember exactly what was said
that I did I did learn okay I got a
start to record so yes no now I know I
record my conversations yeah so what
what was what did you learn by that
experiencing what was it like to be a
journalist you know it was really I
quite enjoyed it I think it's like I
have a lot of respect for experiments
and I am notoriously not allowed
anywhere near a lab I mean my burner
water I burn boiling water frequently so
there's a sense in which like I had a
crush on the experiment and it was just
this total on it was this it was this
respect and and so the journalism was
really pleasurable because it was just
observing and I just remember these
funny observations just watching so many
of the experimentalist students and
thousand-person team and not all of them
are on the ground obviously but there's
no sense of strict hierarchy it's as
though everybody knew what to do and you
know and they wouldn't move kind of like
I said slowly like not spacestation
slowly but this sort of sense of it's
just there's and hundreds of people all
knowing what to do I mean it just it's
kind of mind-blowing yeah right yeah and
that it's real they built something real
based on things that we do on paper and
that connect and just has my total
admiration it'll never stop surprising
me you know my total admiration and I
think that one of the reasons where I
got along with the experimentalist so
well is because that was so obvious on
my face but yeah I mean they did it and
your journalism wasn't just you know
talking here
interviews you were there at the
different places you visited yeah
fieldwork etc yeah I mean I really think
I was trying to write that book like a
novel that was that was the target the
target was Ray as a character Ray has
lines what Ray said stuff and it's
raised dialogue and that it could be
fiction for as long as I could maintain
it it could literally have opened in
read a so Ray was a fictitious character
with lines and and that came from Ray
that idea because his speech is so
spectacular though the rhythm of it the
cadence the swearing I delight of the
swearing out which I and and it just was
Who am I
it was almost sub journalism I mean I
don't know who am I to tell this story
right ray tells a story
Kip tells a story Barry tells a story
even Rabi vote who had a very dark
relationship with Lego at the end tells
his story and I don't interpret I don't
sit there and trying to say what the
truth is
yeah and I simply convey as best that I
can
what they say so it really should be
like a novel where there's not a
narrator who declares to you what the
truth is and what's real but you you get
caught up in the characters and you
decide for yourself when you write a
book like that I mean there's two sides
obviously right there's your you have
some standards you want a really good
book you have a vision but then there's
an audience that reads it right so we
get a feeling from what you're saying
about how there's certain circumstances
under which it's just the right thing to
do you have to tell things in this
narrative way rather than a straight
forward by the pedagogical way how does
the audience receive it are they
outraged that you're not just giving
them the
you know simple drawing of a dramaturg
is actually oh my god that's a good
point it's really funny the biggest
complaint I've ever gotten about this
book is that it didn't have figures and
it was a really clear decision with Dan
my editor and I we talked about it if
it's really a novel in that spirit you
don't put pictures on and so can it be
conjured up solely with the words and I
think that because people anticipated a
nonfiction book they they demanded
figures it was literally the only
complaint of consistently good and you
know and I think we made the right call
but I get that it was uncomfortable it's
mostly because of expectations right
it's not that it didn't work that I
wanted or what is expected something yes
have figures right why doesn't your book
have figures yeah yeah yeah and so and I
would say that some mostly I feel people
really got it
but I mean the figures aside I get that
it's hard to visualize so I appreciate
that
there are novels that can put figures in
because they're doing the opposite
they're playing with that you know we
get like Dave Eggers plays against type
and puts figures in his books I get it
totally so this was a call but but but
that but most people I feel really got
it
they got that it was a climbing Mount
Everest story they got that it was sort
of a tragicomedy it's nonsense
occasionally would be totally
misunderstood like somebody'd be like oh
if only you would know and they
succeeded you would have written a book
about and it's like oh my god that you
did not like that you didn't get it and
that happens that's okay that we
shouldn't pass by this without you know
expressing our mutual admiration for the
exquisite mnestheus the LIGO experiment
yeah the fact they did this I remember
you know inviting people to give talks
just 10 years ago and they would give
talks on here's like oh here's the
update here's what we want to do the
audience members who are you know
physics faculty professors really
shaking our heads that you'll never yeah
it's not gonna happen
they literally thought they'd the
proverbial day we want you know we won't
implicate people cuz it was fair it was
actually I was there to be credit not
just a few you know people there's a lot
of people really smart really insightful
really thoughtful people had every
reason to believe it would fail and
that's not the interesting story I don't
know what is right right so but they did
measure the vibration of a what is it
the mirrors at 40 kilograms Jesus I
should not have to read my own book
by less than one ten-thousandth of a
proton over four kilometers and what a
stunning yeah technological yeah if it
had failed it would have failed because
nature didn't provide and like we've
already established nature doesn't love
us back nature isn't trying to make us
feel good this is one of the rare cases
where we sort of got lucky right like I
mean yeah we were certainly very helpful
to to find something but the things that
LIGO found were a little bit bigger and
more spectacular than we'd expected oh
yeah I love that I love that out of the
gate flat calls yeah and the reason why
I called the book black hole blows is
cuz Ray said to me in August right
before the discovery obviously neither
of us knew if we don't detect black
holes as thing as a failure and that is
also Ray at his most honest yes he could
have been a politician and said well as
long as we succeeded technologically and
as long as we detect neutron stars or
whatever you know Berber but he didn't
he was so honest to the end if we do not
detect black holes as thing as a failure
so I was like a black hole blues so for
those of us who haven't read the book
yet I did read the book for those of you
out there and podcast land how many
years of his career was very wise
working on LIGO probably 50 I would say
50 so he was a young man at MIT who also
succeeded on other fronts but mostly
because they told him you're not gonna
get tenure working on this crap and they
literally he was building an instrument
it was like a metre and a half
got a start yes like start somewhere in
this ramshackle structure on a table the
instruments now four kilometers long so
he real
and a billion dollars and a billion
dollars that a meter and a half wasn't
gonna cut it but at the time he was
working on this little demo prototype
his colleagues were saying things like I
could do better looking out the window
if the Sun blew up
you wouldn't even hear it with this
instrument he was like it's true you
think I do better looking out the window
China that was my single study so that's
discouraging and what I wait you gotta
love about Ray is that he said okay I'm
gonna spend three years doing an
industry study to determine if it's
feasible how big how expensive what the
technological cost and requirements will
be to make this instrument so this is 50
years of his life I mean 50 years was
life and you have to remember and a lot
of people think the estimate turned on
it was immediately successful in the
year 2000 it was running while those
black holes that were detected in 2015
were colliding you know they were
orbiting each other and it was still too
quiet for that very sophisticated
instrument between 2000 and 2015 to
detect anything silence and that
gravitational waves were there and they
were watching over the earth and they
could not be measured and so to be able
to move to Phase two the advanced
machine and turn it on and to say two
weeks before the detection you know this
could fail and my understanding is that
from the talks I heard some people say
that they heard different things but I
heard talks saying that is that is
exactly what they expected I mean I
heard talk saying in other words when we
turn on LIGO we probably won't see
anything but when we turn on advanced
LIGO we probably where so you know kudos
to the National Science Foundation and
the government for saying we're gonna
give you a billion dollars to build
something to blunt see anything all
right yeah absolutely first generation
machine Kip and Ray and Barry were all
really clear that they weren't
guaranteeing a detection maybe if they
were extremely lucky but they absolutely
were saying we fully anticipate having
to go to a second generation to advanced
LIGO before we'll make a detection so
it's it's possible that you have written
more
narrative Li oriented science physics
books than any other person doesn't
include people who don't publish so I
get a lot of letters yeah I think we
should start a Facebook page for all who
write us letters just to point them in
that direction you know the classic
story right I think yeah I heard it
attributed to John Wheeler where he
would get letters from different
crackpots and then he would put them in
contact with each other oh I didn't say
you should talk to this guy and that but
both of them would come back and saying
why did you point me to him he's a
crackpot but this is not transitive
right like they think that everyone else
is also a cracker except that doesn't
work anyway so did we learn something
about the efficacy of this kind of way
of talking about science is there
something we get at I mean science is
done by human beings it's true but it's
a cliche but true and you could write
you could have written books about you
know street builders or something like
that yeah I mean yes there's something
specific about the way science is done
that is different and interesting by
telling the stories as stories per se I
mean to my mind yes and I think that I
love the abstraction of science I love
it
it's what moved me when I was frustrated
that people were still trying to figure
out what the manual continent okay I
drove me insane because it can't be
locked in one human's mind it has to be
shareable there's something about math
and physics that is transcendent right
it belongs to all of us nobody is saying
what did Einstein mean nobody learns
relativity by reading Einsteins papers
right right you'd learn it because we
all own it as soon as he gave it to us
it's a gift
it's ours it's a hundred percent ours we
can use it like
a hammer right right and there's
something about that that just broke my
heart when I discovered that when I
realized what physics really was when I
got away from this negative stereo
foolish stereotype of reciting facts
when I realized oh my god this is a tool
that's been given to me and it belongs
to everybody when I think that there's
something about that that speaks to our
humanity we inherited these concepts
these abilities because we're
evolutionarily involved under forces
dictated by physics you know it's in our
minds it's such a wonderful thing and so
I think that to dispel the sense of this
is solely about facts and to realize
that this is very much about humanity
and something shared and something you
know that could unite us and there was
this moment when they announced the
discovery of the gravitational wave
detection and I know it was hard to
understand that people weren't really
sure what it was but honestly I'm sure
you had a similar experience it was like
the whole world paused yeah I was on I
was doing interviews with you know
remotely with guitar you know cutter I
just might my pronunciation I it's still
a hunk of dermis yeah that's amazing it
was like this moment where we all
realized for a second we're under the
same sky yeah yeah I mean I wrote a book
about the Higgs boson which is the other
exactly discovery of that magnitude
we've had the last ten years that's
right and it's it's an international
team of people working together anything
exquisite harmony I think people should
think about the Nobel Peace Prize for
these experiments because they really
are internationally transcendent
culturally racially religiously
transcended experiments that involve the
whole world working together on some
completely benign yet fascinating I mean
what could be more worthy of the Nobel
Peace Prize on something like that well
I had this quote actually sadly forget
who was from but in my book if the
United Nations worked as well as Atlas
and CDF collaborations at CERN
we would have world peace that's exactly
and then the irony during my interview
with um al-jazeera TV was that they were
about to ask me they prepped me they're
like we're gonna ask you a question
about what this means for Humanity so
it's not to say something rousing about
how we're all under the same sky and you
know and then they're like I'm sorry we
have to take a break for the war in Iraq
Trude itself sometimes it's interesting
I forgot to say this is just coming back
to something earlier but this idea of
being a journalist and going in there
and doing interviews because you said
you enjoyed it maybe so I didn't when I
wrote the higgs-boson book yeah I was I
didn't like it I mean I'm married to one
of the world's great science journalists
so I know how it's done it's not me
right yeah and so I said like you know
interviewing is not for me and I say
this hasn't been genuine you for the
podcast so have weird that what happened
what went terribly chatting well no the
difference was then I wrote the big
picture and again I interviewed people
but I wasn't looking for anecdotes and
stories I was trying to figure out what
they were thinking right so I talked to
philosophers and biologists and whatever
and that I loved right so like I mean
you're much better than I am at caring
about the human stories specifically
telling me I'm never gonna be the one to
describe the beard on his face no and I
have one line about Rabi vote which is
one of my favorite lines on the book
from Allah to say that about my own book
I don't know if that sounds bad but
about how he looked at me through wilted
orchids because his eyes he had this it
was literally like wilted orchids you
know I do like that ya know exactly you
have to do what you're good at it and I
recognize my remember we had this
conversation it's so fascinating yeah
and maybe the other aspect of journalism
I wouldn't enjoy as much which is really
how journalism is written for papers
it's Tom Wolfe 300 opsin ready
yes exactly long-form lord knows you I'm
not
about it it would be so fun to be short
form and stuff out but I can't do it
he's my writer friends I amazed them by
saying I enjoy writing books unless give
me a hundred thousand words I had at my
house yeah yeah I mean cuz it takes me a
while to do the whole structure and
think about what you know what the
different architecture of a new book is
gonna be and I'm always lost in it and
it takes me that long to do it that's
how long it takes me but I want to give
you a chance before we go plug your big
on going I don't wanna call it a new
project but you you're here in New York
and you have this amazing public event
series that you're doing out there in
Brooklyn out there in the suburbs this
where we are now we're up at Columbia
and Barnard and I call this upstate
Manhattan in the parks and a sweet hour
away which we can take a ferry to from
Wall Street is pioneer acculturate hook
Red Hook is slightly inaccessible
because it actually the ground cannot
support a subway system so you have to
get there by boat or foot or bus but it
is also a kind of pristine part of New
York City because of it and my dear dear
dear friend Dustin Yellen started
pioneer works there he bought this old
ironworks Factory from you know 1850s
and renovated it to become a cultural
center and the founding artistic
director is Gabriel Florence who's just
been incredibly visionary and an
aggressive and interesting and unafraid
and so it started mostly as an art
center and your works
yeah pioneer works and and we brought
science in there now we have a science
very strong science presence in some
sense our science events are the biggest
events we do we have we do not fully
understand our audience but they come
out for it and you've been you've been
to anima you were in one of my answers
was such a pleasure people love it
people love a presented an accessible
way hey and you're doing a prick
the other way but it's certainly very
accepting I think what we're doing which
I'm trying to understand retro actively
is that people feel like the scientists
are coming to their house okay so it's
free open to the public and it's very
much in this cultural community senator
that's open and welcomed and people hang
out in the garden and they stay late and
they talk and there's bees and there's
booze and there's food and there's you
know we do pop-up exhibits a friend of
my was like I was in the longest beer
line and I got to the front and it was a
genetics experiment so some things to
fear don't feel like it's there you're
not that yeah so I think that right
people people what want it to feel like
it's theirs and and so we talk in a
really high level we do not and as you
know from our event
I don't prep people in part because I
don't want them to have lectures and I
don't want them to yes no PowerPoint
open nothing like that make and we
taught in some times we have to stop you
know Frank will check when the Nobel
Prize who's a good friend of both of
ours who came from MIT to give a talk
said something like well as you all know
[Laughter]
can't do that no but it's okay so we
stopped and we translate but we let me
let Frank talk as Frank talks it's a
great I'd never heard that idea that
part of the charm is the scientists
coming to our house right I mean it's
another another twist on the idea of
telling the human side telling the
stories bring people into our house and
I think that you know actually and this
podcast is also in the surface of the
same ideal that there shouldn't be a
dividing line between science and other
parts of human intellectual life whether
it's philosophy or economics or whatever
and so this is definitely contributing
to that oh thank you for saying that
that's probably the most important
philosophy behind pioneer works we don't
come out of the womb as scientists or
artists we come out as both and all
things you know every child palpates
the world every child puts things in
their mouth and then tries to figure out
what it is and every child develops
their own sense of time and space
there's a forward and a backward in the
fascinating revelations that children
aren't taught but they discover and
every child is an artist and I don't
want to bring scientists to go be
artists professionally I'm not into that
and I don't bring artists to come and be
you know III don't I actually don't like
the Sai art mix but what I do love is
just human beings rubbing elbows and
feeling that they live in a bigger world
and feeling less isolated can't think of
a better place to end Jan 11 thanks so
much for being on the podcast thanks
Sean fun as always
[Music]